name review meme review main review
welcome everybody to my brand new show
called main review you guessed it this
is a completely original idea that no
one has ever done before and therefore I
am proud to copyright this idea so that
no one else can do what I am doing mean
review I will take down anyone with
copyright infringement I have lawyers
beware or else I will be buried on this
very first mean review it's this is a
historic moment of this channel we're
going to pick a mean somewhat recent
maybe you've seen it a week ago it was a
webcomic and it goes like this my bike
got stolen recently sad face but I think
whoever stole it was probably more happy
to get it than I am sad to lose it the
total happiness in the world
increased so whatever now despite being
the most [ __ ] sense of logic I've
ever heard it's an innocent little
webcomic but boy avoided the internet
not take this well people immediately
started to parody this way of thinking
and some of the responses are very funny
sonic got killed recently I was pretty
bummed about it but I think whoever
killed him was probably more happy to
see him die than I am sad to lose him
the total happiness in the world
increased so whatever as long as the
total happiness in the world is
increased
whatever am i right we also have my bike
got stolen recently I was pretty bummed
out about it but then I thought where's
my [ __ ] bike these are pretty
innocent parodies altered even retweeted
them himself but then there's
then there's the more dank ones my wife
got [ __ ] recently I was pretty bummed
about it but I think whoever [ __ ] her
was probably more happy to get it on
than I am sad to get cut the total
happiness in the world after this
amazing way of thinking sort of spread
around the internet this comic strip got
renamed to bike cook the creator of the
meme reached out and said please stop
calling me by cook and their response
was I guess he just doesn't appreciate
that the joy other experience in
perpetuating the bike caca mean is
greater than the joy he would have
experienced it not being come yeah
as can happen with the Internet and
gotten things going viral it can be a
bit overwhelming and Shen even said that
he's gonna take a break because of
personal stuff and then of course people
made my favorite artist my favorite
artist stopped posting recently I was
pretty bummed out about it but I think
whoever book was okay
alright but I think whoever bullied him
into it was probably more happy to do it
than I am sad to loosen the total
happiness in the world increase so
whatever conclusion of this mean I
really enjoy it all turns work some of
them are really really funny when I was
looking around he's a great artist no
doubt about it
and he even said himself he's okay with
the means and the reason he took a break
was because other personal issues that
somehow appeared at the exact same time
so you know he's embracing the joke and
which a it's always appreciated you know
it never looks good if you don't at
least but and even some of the responses
that I saw underneath his tweet
literally if you go to the the tweeting
question the first response is this
precise [ __ ] is what hedonism is a
exactly trash and a society based on
your [ __ ] concept would collapse I'm
not saying you should be more upset I'm
saying that the reason you aren't means
that you don't understand utility and
deontology learn and while I'm at it's
like Jesus Christ dude
at the end of the day it's just a
webcomic and while I'm at it how regular
and high income do you have to write
something like oh my god I understand
I'm taking a break and at the end of the
day Who am I or anyone else to tell them
how to feel about something happening
you know although the whole letting go
of something I sort of understand that
in the sense of when I donate stuff that
I maybe have a personal attachment to
maybe some sweater that I don't really
like anymore but it has some sort of
sentimental value and my doors
[Music]
[Music]
but this is not the first time web
comics have been criticized there's the
famous BuzzFeed web comic books from
Adam which some would say not me of
course I love books from Adam it's my
favorite web comic of all time some
would say it's a bit lazy I mean I don't
see it
I see attention and detail into every
single strip and I definitely don't see
reuploading the same webcomic two years
later which I have never done with my
videos but my favourite webcomic meme of
all time will claim is this if you know
this meme you know what this means if
you don't know what this means it's
hella confusing what about this meme
does this ring a bell this is the same
meme it is this one now I had seen this
meme for a long time and I didn't really
get it and it's a sort of meme that you
need to know the backstory up to get so
in case you have don't know the
backstory don't worry I'm going to spend
the next ten minutes explaining it to
you because there's nothing inherently
funny about this comic strip itself but
at the same time it is
mathis a comic strip is from
control-alt-delete which you may have
heard of before it sort of came from the
Renaissance of web comics back in 2008
the the four-by-four kind of comic strip
was paralyzed and it was about two guys
sitting on a couch playing video games
very hilarious but surprisingly
control-alt-delete was very popular it
did really well for its time and it sort
of worked that Tim Tim would add himself
into the cartoon in the best way
possible I would
my name is Tim Buckley I'm a 24 year old
gamer I played every violent game in
existence and I have never killed anyone
there are millions of gamers just like
me and we're getting sick of people like
you blaming your problem on us ignorant
cautious violence not videogames man up
and take responsibility
we outnumber you and the people that
think like you don't despite being very
popular control-alt-delete it sort of
became more and more criticized over
time for lacking how to tell a joke
properly which is ironic of me to talk
about but Tim would often blow out the
punch line before the end of the strip
and sort of beating the joke itself to
death and it became a meme to remove the
middle strip and somehow his comic strip
would be then funnier all ready to go I
don't know you haven't told me where it
is
that we are going and done finally when
did we get a bowling ball
control-alt-delete was also criticized
for having way too much unnecessary text
now where have we heard that before a
webcomic with too much text I can't
possibly think of anything oh oh oh oh
now the years sort of went by between
between slightly sexist jokes and
slightly racist jokes again ironic for
me to talk about I don't know where
comes this comic strip titled loss and
it's sort of hit people for being so
blatantly out of nowhere that it sort of
became the joke itself no one was
expecting this and the 4x4 panel of
comics is typically used to make a setup
and then the last strip being the
punchline and now the last strip being
the punchline of a mascara which again
really displays Tim's inability to
properly tell the story now don't get me
wrong the miscarriage here is not the
joke the joke is that
the edits of this make fun of how
completely misplaced it is and the way
that Tim handled the subject matter in
such a terrible terrible way that the
joke itself became an inside joke and
boy oh boy did it spawn up some of the
greatest meme creations I have ever seen
mmm it's some of the most obscure [ __ ]
I've ever seen and people really
appreciate the minimalism out of this
meme that you can really reduce it down
to just a few lines and it's equally
emotionally captivating as the original
how how is this possibly oh I see it
even that [ __ ] kanji can be
interpreted as I lost me is that a lost
meme I think it is even in Dark Souls
someone made the mean inside Dark Souls
someone say that the CAD meme or lost
mean it's the perfect mean perhaps the
greatest meme of all time it's universal
it's adaptable and it turns to joke
against its creator
it's a beautiful meme and of course
there is this so now you know about the
last do you get it I would rate the bike
chuck meme and solid eight out of ten
I'm nine and I'm gonna have to stick it
to the lost meme for a 10 out of 10 this
has been episode one of meme review
thank you for leaving your likes one
like means the world to me
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I SWAT fam
mean review